Jeremy Allen White's estranged wife
Addison Timlin opens up about life as a
single mom days after filing for divorce
you know it's a lot it's a lot on
Mother's Day the actress shared an
emotional message about the challenges
of raising kids alone alongside these
pics with her two daughters Ezra and
Dolores whom she shares with the bear
star she writes quote being a single mom
is not how I pictured it and it is so
hard Addison calls it exhausting and
even more so lonely particularly when
something magical happens and you have
to tell yourself don't forget this
because there's no witness by your side
Jeremy and Addison met in 2008 and
welcomed their first child Ezra 10 years
later I think you always want your
children to outshine you I just didn't
know it was going to happen this early
in 2019 Addison and Jeremy tied the knot
and the following year welcome from
their second daughter Dolores
their last public appearance together
was at the Golden Globes in January when
Jeremy won best actor in a comedy series
for his role in the bear just like all
day I've been like a jittery mess and
then I think right at that moment it was
just like at its most I was vibrating
almost you know
um and just holding on to my wife's hand
really really tight fast forward to May
11th and Addison filed for divorce in
the filing obtained by E.T she lists the
date of Separation as September 1st
2022. a source tells ET that she and
Jeremy attempted to work things out
before deciding to split the pair was
having trust issues during their
relationship that ultimately led to
their divorce I'm curious what you and
your wife think about your new title The
Internet's new boyfriend have you heard
this yet I've heard about it I have like
a pretty nice like healthy distance uh I
have Instagram I don't have Twitter I
don't I don't really like paid too much
attention
um but it's it's flattering it's very
nice yeah this despite the tough times
Addison is pushing through in her post
she says she's feeling so peaceful today
and so deeply in love with her children
quote doing it alone has given me more
strength and more empathy and More Tears
than anything else in my life ever has
[Music]